if the witcher is where you turn when
you need a monster hunter for hire
here are five other titles worth
checking out on this week's bench guide
the netflix fantasy show based on the
popular book series and video game has
one fresh season currently under its
armor and fans love henry cavill as
geralt of rivia and all the fantasy
elements and dark humor that this show
brings
so from warrior princesses to vampire
hunters to more henry cavill
this list is everything you're searching
for starting with our editor's pick
the netflix animated show castlevania
this medieval fantasy that was inspired
by a video game has turned in three
straight fresh seasons so far
and follows a vampire hunter attempting
to save all of eastern europe from
dracula
critics have praised this compelling
adaptation for its spectacular visuals
calling it devilishly fun with humor
heart
and a lot of bloody action while you
wait for season four you can binge the
first three seasons in just under eight
and a half hours and why not it's
basically the witcher in animated form
and shining through with our actors
spotlight pick this week is the showtime
series
the tudors featuring the witchers henry
cavill alongside star jonathan rhys
myers this show with
three or four fresh seasons chronicles
the early years of king henry viii
as one of the first major roles in his
career cavill is part of a cast that
critics described as gorgeous able
and handsome to go along with sturdy
acting and the show's
stunning period detail you can binge
this show in about 38 hours and if i'm
being honest it's gonna leave you
wanting more henry cavill and our
throwback pick this week is taking us
all the way back to the mid 90s my
favorite place for xena warrior princess
this action-adventure series dominated
syndication as it aired for six seasons
starting in 1995 and follows xena played
by lucy lawless a mighty warrior
princess with a dark past who is out to
redeem herself
xena actually began as a recurring
nemesis on the show hercules the
legendary journeys but warrior princess
actually went on to become the more
successful show which is why critics
called it a swashbuckling actioner that
transcends its origin as a spin-off and
becomes a fully realized saga in its own
right
it will take you about a hundred hours
to binge a series and while you do keep
an eye out for
the boy star carl irvin who played both
julius caesar and cupid
at various times during the show's run
and sitting on the throne as our
audience pick this week
is the last kingdom this history drama
series from bbc america and netflix
tells the story of utrid
an anglo-saxon raised by danes who is
forced to choose between the country of
his birth and the people of his
upbringing
witcher fans will love the battle scenes
and key characters in the last kingdom
while the critics say it fuses beautiful
cinematography and magnificent action
sequences to create
highly gratifying historical drama you
can measure first four seasons in 36
hours and then just think of how awesome
you'll be with the sword
hypothetically speaking of course and
finally our under the radar pick this
week is the bbc show
atlantis running for two seasons
starting back in 2013 this fantasy drama
series follows a young man named jason
played by jack donnelly whose search for
his missing father leads him to the
ancient and mysterious city of atlantis
despite being cancelled after just two
seasons critics say that atlantis
succeeds as a giddy mixture of mythology
and pulp fantasy with a charming and
family-friendly vibe
it will take you just under 19 hours to
binge this series and then you'll
totally be able to cross atlantis off
your bucket list of places to visit
okay friends well hopefully this list
based on the witcher will make your next
few bench sessions
that much richer be sure to let us know
what you are currently streaming in the
comments and also do not forget to check
out
our new podcast called rotten tomatoes
is wrong a podcast from rotten tomatoes
because fresh rotten
is just the beginning of the
conversation and new episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't want to
miss out on any future recommendations
based around the movies and shows that
you love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the fun
as always we can't thank you enough for
watching the rotten tomatoes binge guide
and we'll see your face in the next
video
bye
you